[Music]
hello hello welcome hi everyone thanks
for coming it's been a long day huh it's
been a long three days and I know I know
staring at myself really appreciate all
of you sticking around and coming to our
session so just one more time thank you
everyone it's good to have you with us
this is miles miles Boren's miles is a
developer advocate on Google cloud we've
been working together for the last you
know he also happens to be the director
of the nodejs
technical steering committee and of
course he's a long time no js' lover I
think you're first the first time you
use nodejs was for an hour installation
nice so this is starin staring as a
product manager for Google cloud
platform on the server list team and
we've been working really closely on new
node.js technologies previously was
involved in this stack driver error
reporting product and use node in
production in 2011 is that like zero
four or zero six zero six zero six did
anyone start with node zero six in the
audience right on now is that was buggy
I think that's like right when they
introduced util but fun fact of its
tarrant his wedding invitation was
actually written in javascript and it's
still online and that means your wedding
invitation will never break the web all
right so who can name this French pastry
so it's called a milford literally
translating 2,000 layers so it's
basically a cake made of many many many
layers so one of my teacher used to say
in French to problem is a mid-face the
show's sound so translating every
problem is a mill file of simple things
so you should understand every problem
can be broken down into many simple
things and I think this is also true for
software for code but also for software
architectures if you break down your big
app into simple things it will be
simpler if into you break them down into
micro-services but that brings us
through micro-services why
micro-services well maybe you your ad
has grown too big maybe it is actually
hard to understand develop maintain
manage this is why micro services can be
your solution you break up the monolith
you dig up all those micro services you
make them simpler to understand and
maintain and potentially each service
will be written in different language
owned by a different team and deployed
independently as a consequence they will
scale independently if you decouple them
the scaling is independent - and by
making them more fine-grained that will
result in a better utilisation of your
resources that will result in a lower
bill for you and lastly micro services
pair great with nodejs due to the
asynchronous nature of noches so micro
services break up the monolith scale
independently and pair great with nodejs
but what is no js'
so I was given this slide no js'
JavaScript how many people like
JavaScript suite so I don't know if any
of you have seen this little emoji thing
before the rocket turtle that was the
node.js logo is kind of like a joke sub
stack drew this turtle on a rocket ship
because javascript was not supposed to
be a fast language and is like pretty
amazing how fast both as a runtime but
also for iteration like note is one of
those things that just you have an idea
and you can get it done in like 10 or 15
minutes because someone's already
written the module you just need to find
it but so at its base node is a
JavaScript runtime we take the v8
virtual machine that comes in the Chrome
browser we wrap it with libuv which is
an underlying architecture wrapping all
the system calls and that kind of
abstracts all the different platforms
and allows developers to just write
javascript and be able to do compute
write servers and all those different
things it allows you to leverage your
front-end skills
it's event-driven what that means is
that compute is driven by events
something computes when something
happens that can be an HTTP request that
can be some sort of message coming over
a socket it can be user input with a
keyboard it can be some sensor if you're
working with IOT any form of i/o so
anytime there's input some sort of
compute runs the aventure of an
architecture plays really great with
async non-blocking i/o multiple things
can run in parallel without blocking
each other when i make some sort of
request over a socket i'm able to
suspend let other things execute and
resume when i'm done without requiring
the developer to program any of this it
just happens many events execute without
blocking each other and this ends up
being really great for web servers
because it means multiple people can
connect to the same process at the same
time and it just works you don't have to
worry about mutex you don't have to
worry about timing you just worry about
handling the events so to sum that up
no js' is a JavaScript runtime that's
event-driven with async non-blocking i/o
and the last term that we need to define
from the title of this talk is several s
so who here is using a seven s product
so we should agree that there are a lot
of definitions for several s I'm going
to highlight here the key
characteristics that we will use along
this talk the first one that to me is
the main characteristic is that you pay
for what you use so it's a bidding model
if you don't use it you don't pay and
then the bill is proportional to your
usage of course you don't need to
provision in advance any resource all of
this is done on demand so why are we
able to achieve that bidding model
because of an operational model so a
service product will scale with usage
without having to worry about it
it grows with you form a single
developer to a company with thousands of
developers it follow your usage and why
can it scale well because of a
programming model the cloud providers
takes care of the rest you focus on your
code that means that no infrastructure
management no VM management everything
is abstracted from you so you focus on
your code that also means that you focus
on delivering business value and value
to your users
so to recap several s pay for what you
use it scales and allows you to focus on
code this is the principles that we are
going to these are the principles we are
going to use along that talk and you
will see it's not actually not only for
computes so Google Cloud has a number of
different service offerings we have
cloud functions how many people here
have been using
noting cloud functions so far cool
we've got App Engine standard we've got
datastore cloud storage bigquery pub/sub
dataflow ml engine the firebase suite as
well as app scripts and all of these
different products what defines them as
service and makes them all server this
is the fact that you don't have to
manage them we will scale them for you
we'll manage them for you you can
utilize them as much as you need it and
today we are very proud to share with
you the preview of node.js on the App
Engine standard environment thank you so
yes we are adding a new language to App
Engine stand out no js' we will release
it in a few weeks so let's let's see
let's see let's see a small demo of
node.js on App Engine stand out minds is
going to tell you more about it so this
package JSON file is outlining a hello
world application we have a single start
script that calls node on server J s
which fun little fact if you don't
define the start script and you just run
NPM start that's actually the default
commander we'll just do which can be
really confusing if you're not expecting
it to do that and it has a single
dependent dependency which is Express
here's our Express app we're making an
app using Express we have a single route
and we celebrate nodejs on App Engine
standard we listen on an environment
variable for the port or fall back to
8080 for local development and there's
one more thing that we'll need to get
this on to App Engine standard that's
just tiny bitty animal this one line of
yamo runtime no js8 is the only extra
thing that you need to add to the
majority of nodejs apps and it will work
as soon as you run a single command and
that count command is g-cloud app deploy
so
starin has something loaded up on his
computer so we're gonna switch over to
it right now and you're gonna see
scarrans in the cloud show he's got that
app that we were just showing you and
he's going to type in that command that
I just mentioned g-cloud app deploy
so this is how you know it's a real demo
but we haven't actually deployed yet
we're ready to deploy now you ready
let's do it so we're starting to employ
and in the time it takes to deploy I'm
gonna try to list all the things I like
about it
so it's an idiomatic no time no drun
time in environments that means we're
using the exact version of node that
gets published by nodejs there's no
special runtimes or no special api's
it's the same app you can run in other
places it scales to zero so when you're
not using it you're not paying for it
it's a managed runtime so that means
everything but your code and and the
node modules that you're using will get
updated by us if there's a security fix
that needs to land into node or open SSO
and trust me there are we're gonna patch
that for you without you or your users
really ever noticing oh wow I couldn't
even get to it it's already deployed you
also get NPM install on the cloud so
that also did NPM install you get hybrid
Marty monitoring for free and free HTTP
wow that was fast
[Music]
and we can go and we can see the service
right now is already running
oh the bar hiding it so there you go
this service has been deployed we're
already running it and this is in my
opinion like a it's a really great user
experience being able to deploy have it
up in the cloud so quickly and be able
to share that with people to take a look
so now that we're done with the demo
we're gonna talk a little bit more so -
so this was no js' on App Engine sterile
environments it is idiomatic
which means that you can use any module
from the NPM registry that you want
there is no API or language restriction
as you've seen it deploys fast and
scales instantly and as Miles said it is
secure so you get one-click HTTP for
your custom domains and it auto updates
so I will now do a deep dive into three
updated pieces of our infrastructure the
first one that it is what we call
internally faster-than-light builds so
what stands when you type g-cloud at
deploy we will first only upload the
files that have actually changed since
last time okay this is an optimization
for the upload process the fastest
denied build arrives after so what we do
is we look at your package dot JSON and
package lock dot JSON to install your
dependencies in the cloud so we do npm
install for you in the cloud good but
actually so this is what we defined as
the speed of light but actually if we
notice that your package dot JSON and
your dependencies haven't changed well
what we are going to do is just give you
what we just gave you before if you do a
new deployment so we use we use or
caching system to give to give you the
cached modules and that's how we can go
faster than light these are the first
piece of updated infrastructure for this
new runtime the second one is a new
runtime environment
so let's hear it a bit of the technical
stack so first you gave us your code
when you did Jeep load up deploy so this
is your application code as I said we
installed the node modules for you
so including the native modules they can
be any modules good and that of course
there is no js' and here this is enough
the Shelf nodejs there's no no special
customization here node is relying on
the OS packages and for example you
might have heard about the headless
chrome and yes all of the packages
needed to run to run headless chrome are
present in the App Engine image and that
lives on top of a regular oh s which is
open to the last week this is node OS
packages and Ubuntu are automatically
updated without you having to worry
about it so we will automatically update
your node.js version the minor and
patched version of the node.js the OS
package in the u.s. is also
automatically updated all of that lives
in a secured sandbox and this is a new
sandbox technology that we are
introducing with this new runtime under
the hood the sandbox is based on G visor
so divisor is a container or runtime
sandbox that we open sourced last week
check it out
this is all new runtime environment and
the last piece of infrastructure I would
like to highlight is automatic scaling
so what what is automatic scaling let's
take an example so App Engine constantly
monitors the instance capacity and
traffic that your application capacity
in traffic and it ensures that the
appropriate number of instances are
available to run your application so
what does that mean let's take an
example so as I said if there is no
request arriving to your application
there is no instance scheduled
and when I say instance it's not a VM
instance it's a it's an abstract that we
rename instance okay now some traffic
arrives to your application well we will
scale up as fast as possible
one instance here I'm gonna pause for a
second I'm gonna highlight one concept
that is very important for developers
the very first of these requests will
hit what we call a cold start that means
that this request will actually hit the
instance while it is starting up and
this usually results in a higher latency
is unusual of course we try to learn not
we try but we do put up the instance
very very fast but you also have a
responsibility here you have to ensure
that your start command is fast too so
in the start script of your package.json
make sure to not do things like build or
lot of initialization do the minimum
required to start your application
because this will have an impact on the
cold start of your application okay so
here as I said the very first request
will hit this cold start but there the
next ones everything is fine but then
your traffic we start doing with a
little bit and here before this first
instance arrives at capacity we will
anticipate that you need a second one
and we will actually schedule a second
one so that when you actually need it
it's there doesn't need to scan more and
now let's imagine your your app is is is
featured on a popular blog post and you
have a huge spike of traffic well don't
worry
App Engine scales very fast so will be
scale up instances as much as needed you
control you can tell us a maximum of
number of instances if if that matters
to you and of course when things go good
go down well we will ramp down the
number of instances to zero so that's
what we call automatic scaling you did
not have to do anything to get this
behavior
but this is not new at all my app engine
has been doing that for ten years ten
years now what is new is that actually
we updated or automatic scaling
algorithm so the deal dates include it
is more predictable as a developer you
will better understand how it behaves
when you look at your instance chart you
will you will better understand it
second it actually improves instance
utilization and performance so we we
measured a reduction of 30% of those
cold starts so that means that the tail
latency of all phone ads across our of
App Engine has went down and also better
utilization means lower bills for
everybody using App Engine and this was
released in the last month the third
point are new settings that we are
introducing to better control this
automatic scaling algorithms those new
settings help you balance between cost
and performance also as I said help you
cap the number of instances so that you
can cap your bill but also the number of
Dedic or the database connections for
example so this was suite pieces of
instruction we updated up to you minds
so we built a product with no js'
comprised of microservices to share with
you today and Stan's going to demo it on
the machine for us right now
all right so go for it so we created a
webpage launcher and we're able to put
an address into the submission bar and
it will start watching it and at five
minute increments it's gonna use
headless Chrome to take a screen capture
of the website and it's going to compare
it to other screen captures and it's
going to only take screen captures when
there's actually been a difference in
the page this website allows you to set
any number of different websites to
watch and this has been a lot of fun to
use unlike the Google website to see the
changes to the Google header you could
use it to watch your own site to make
sure that things aren't going down if
you have a personal page that isn't
changing a lot but it was a way for us
to experiment with breaking things into
different services and put together a
really great example so Stan did you
have anything you wanted to add to that
I want to tell you how it's done
that sounds great let's switch back to
the slides so this is your product this
is our application or website watcher
how did we build it well every five
minutes there is a cron job that will
trigger of first micro-services is micro
service is called task scheduler the job
of this micro service is to ask all
database for a list of webpages to
screenshot when it received this list it
will actually thank you into a pub sub
topic a message for each page to
screenshot
this is our first micro service then pub
sub will dispatch will push to a second
micro service the web pages and the job
of this micro service it has one job is
to take screenshots so as I said
previously this is using headless Chrome
under the hood in order to take those
screenshots so it opens a web page
texture screenshot saves it into Google
Cloud storage that's it's only job
now a new file arrived into cloud
storage this will trigger an event this
will send an events that will trigger a
Google Cloud function that will compare
this new screenshot with the last known
reference screenshot for that webpage we
call it image diff because the job of
that function is to compare two images
and if there is a difference between the
images it will store the new image into
a new folder in Google Cloud storage so
this is how we continuously get the
updates of all of the web pages that we
want to track okay now a user arrives
onto a website
so an HTTP request arrives on to our web
front-end another micro service that
will query our database asking for a
list of web pages you've seen that list
and when I see the detail of one of
those web page we are to display the
screenshots so it also queries cloud
storage so that's how we build our
products for custom microservices or
communicating with each other and now am
is going to tell you more a bit about
the code so the first micro service that
we're showing is our screenshot server
you're gonna notice we're using async
functions because we're App Engine
standard comes with no date out of the
box the we're gonna start a browser
session by a waiting puppeteer to launch
we're going to then await a new page
from the browser object we're gonna
await surfing to that URL will await
setting the viewport to the size of the
image that we want to take and then
we'll await a screen shot in the image
buffer we then await closing the browser
and then we return the image buffer
we're doing a lot of asynchronous work
in here that is going to allow us to use
the same service to pull lots of
different images at the exact same time
without blocking we're able to do it in
a single linear fashion without having
to manage a whole bunch of callbacks or
any sorts of promises although under the
hood there's lots of different promises
going on now
this is deployed using App Engine
standard and there were some other talks
going on this week about headless Chrome
and you can find those if you go and
check the IO web page later so this is
our service that the part of the service
that actually saves to a bucket
similarly we're using a sink and a
weight to be able to do this in a linear
fashion but we go to the bucket we
rename the images to be based on a
timestamp and we save it and await that
information and then log in and because
all of the node.js client libraries
support promises you're going to be able
to use our various client libraries to
talk to all of our various servers using
async/await
right out of the box and then the last
thing that we wanted to show you was the
image diff from our cloud function
that's doing the image diff every time a
new file gets added to a cloud storage
bucket this function is automatically
called and what we wanted to just show
is how quickly from the event that the
function is executed with we can grab
the file and the context at which of
that file inside a cloud storage so we
don't even need to write any logic to
tie the two together we just need one
service to save it and this new service
just reacts and one thing that's really
great about all these different services
is that out of the box if you start
logging stack drivers gonna grab all of
those logs and you're gonna be able to
use stack driver logging to look at all
the logs of what's going on I don't know
about you but I never write a service
right at the first time I run it locally
and then it works differently in the
cloud being able to just log and have it
working is really awesome and for the
demo that we put together you'll see
online later
we used Bunyan and have a pretty robust
logging system that you'll be able to
take a look at so let's look at the
cloud console to see those micro
services in the console so as I said we
do have three App Engine services so you
will see them on the App Engine
dashboard so opening my services or we
have four because I just deployed wine
earlier
you so default screenshot and tasks you
do now we have one cloud function so if
I open it
it will display here image diff as you
see the trigger is a cloud storage
bucket trigger now as much said out of
the box all of your logs are being are
going to be collected into stack driver
logging so here let me filter out some
of those logs and only show the
application nodes that are here so these
are the logs of 4ad across all of those
services so as you see we see we loaded
the website we also what else did we do
we saved screenshots so all of this gets
logged and with a different severity
here we had we had an arrow apparently
and the last thing I wanted to show is
that when your logs go to stock driver
they are going to be collected and
grouped together by stag driver error
reporting so here what you see here is a
list of air groups so all of your arrows
if they are the same are going to be
grouped together and displays add as one
group so this is out of the box when you
use App Engine especially in node.js on
App Engine that is all for the demo of
the resources let's go back to the
slides and now I'm going to talk a
little bit more about how to connect
microservices so of course you can
directly call a service so that's the
case for example when a client calls or
front-end so an HTTP request arrives
that's a direct call it's also the case
when you receive a web hook when you
receive web work that would be a direct
call and lastly to micro-services can
call each other directly of course
another kind of communication between
micro services which actually can be
quite convenient and useful is what we
call a synchronous execution and events
so if you remember every five minutes
one of our service was scheduled so this
is one kind of
scheduled services now you remember any
time we put a file into cloud storage
something happen a function was trigger
so this is another kind of communication
we call that reactive services so when
something happened this is trigger
yeah events another way to do as
increase education is to actually use a
task queue so one service will ank you a
task into a queue and then this queue
will make sure that the task is executed
by a retrying if needed and by
dispatching at the rate that you want so
task queues could be can be quite
convenient for a synchronous task
execution and lastly as we've made in
our demo you can use publish to be share
and subscribe pattern where one service
will publish the message into a pub
subtopic and maybe make one or many
other services that are subscribed to
that topic will receive the message and
lastly maybe this is obvious but sharing
storage is also a way to communicate
between services you can have two
services sharing the same database that
is the kind of connection in our case we
used cloud datastore and Google Cloud
Storage so connecting micro services you
can directly call them you can use a
synchronous execution in events and
share the storage so after kind of
talking about all these different types
of services and products you may be
wondering like when should I use
functions or when should I use App
Engine or maybe when should I use a
kubernetes these decisions are things
that teams need to make so I wanted to
dig a little bit more into functions
first so we talked about events and
async and that's a lot of the
programming model that's used for this
so you have different kinds of triggers
you have pub/sub you have Google Cloud
Storage so whenever something ends up in
a bucket it triggers it
you can have data database transactions
one that's really interesting is logs so
you can have a function run every time
you see things in logs you can use that
to filter certain kinds of error
messages or you know automate page or
duty or something fun like that maybe
maybe not paid for duty but you and you
can also use web hooks any sort of HTTP
can go and call in one of the things is
nice with cloud functions is they can be
really single purpose it has a
well-defined programming model with a
really quick way to get to the data
that's coming in from the event one that
I really like is an emailer
for example so you may have a whole
bunch of different services that need to
send email so if you have one cloud
function that just does all the off and
all the message handling to whatever
email service you're running you can
make email topic on pub/sub and just you
know publish a - from a body and a title
and an email will just go out and let's
say you decide to change your email
provider service you just have to change
that one cloud function and no one else
needs to refactor their code as long as
you have a defined API surface between
all your services that isn't broken you
know you could change it to any language
or you know any service you want to so
on the other hand we have App Engine App
Engine for example HTTP services are
generally what are exposed now it's
multi-purpose though you could use it
for front-end applications you can use
it to serve static resources it does not
have a defined function wrapper so you
can just take any node application for
the most part that you've already been
running and just launch it if you have
multiple different things that are going
multiple routes that you're handling
database queries templating you may find
that running something on App Engine
makes more sense for the use case than a
cloud function but you know you can
define your own compute relationship
cloud functions in App Engine work
really great together
if your team prefers thinking about
things as functions like run with that I
know entire websites that have thousands
of pages and hours and they're written
their entire infrastructure on functions
and there's tons of big node apps that
could just run on App Engine and
as necessary you could really break
apart the problem as it makes sense to
your team as you need to go and they
both share a lot of similarities they're
both going to scale to 0 when you're not
using them you're gonna pay for what you
use and under the hood they're using the
same sandbox they're using the same auto
scaling there's no right or wrong one of
the cool things about it too is you can
start thinking it almost becomes more of
a difference of how you want to think
about your compute and how you want to
factor your code but from an ops
perspective they're very similar and we
also wanted to announce today that no
date is going to be coming to GCF really
soon
so you're going to be able to use all
these features both on cloud functions
as well as app engine all right
to recap deploying nodejs micro-services
service node.js micro services what have
we seen today first breaking up the
monolith so as as you've seen we've
built an entire product made out of very
very simple pieces each of these pieces
is is a few files or even one file for
some of them break up the monolith micro
service architectures can help you build
rich product from a decoupled small
scalable maintainable understandable
components second we showed you a
preview of nodejs
on App Engine standard environment this
is coming in a few weeks and lastly what
you should remember is a Google cloud
platform has everything you need to
build several s micro services using
node.js and personally I can't when - I
can't wait to see what you will build
with no json happenin standout and all
of those products so
thank you thank you
so if you enjoyed the session you can go
to and get your feedback here through
the schedule link you can use web or
Android or iOS just let me know let us
know what you think here are some
resources you'll find the docs for the
App Engine standard you're going to see
the functions and the demo that we were
showing you today is all there and so
just a quick round of applause for
everyone who's watching at home on the
live stream and and one more quick round
of applause you don't really see it but
there's some amazing people at the back
of house and the back here who have been
working all day tirelessly just a round
of applause for them and so don't go yet
well the whole thing one more thing look
under your seats no joking okay
look over there we have a stand where
you can scan your badge and you will
send you invites to try tomorrow or as
soon as we get your emails no genius on
App Engine standard environments if you
give it a try
scan your badge over there thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]